[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho ascoltato ho guardato centinaia di
the top nella mia vita ma non avrei mai
pensato di tenerne uno e non sono
proprio dove avevo programmato di essere
alzi la mano chi di voi è nella
situazione personale familiare o fisica
o professionale e lavorativa ed
economica che aveva pianificato anni fa
mi chiedo quindi se chi siamo dove siamo
sia il risultato di una pianificazione
di un metodo di un controllo attento
delle nostre azioni e delle relative
conseguenze oppure sia il risultato di
una serie di reazioni ad avvenimenti
casuali che ci sono successi siamo
padroni del nostro destino
siamo padroni del nostro destino è un
mantra che ci siamo sentiti ripetere
tante volte in diversi contesti aveva
convinzione che la nostra vita non sia
lasciata al caso ma siamo noi ad avere
le redini
indubbiamente ci assicura siamo noi i
padroni del nostro futuro siamo noi che
decidiamo il nostro futuro con la nostra
volontà
con la nostra tenacia con la nostra
bravura ma è davvero così perché a me
invece a volte sembra di vivere una vita
come se fosse una corsa in equilibrio su
una fune
avete presente quei giochini gli endless
anni che vanno tanto di moda adesso dove
l'imprevisto è sempre dietro l'angolo
un imprevisto lavorativo un imprevisto
di salute è un imprevisto logistico
anche piccolo anche positivo non sto
parlando necessariamente di grandi
tragedie arriva l'imprevisto
e saltano i piani vengono disattese le
mie aspettative e quindi la prima
domanda che mi faccio turno dubbi e
sempre ho sbagliato qualcosa poteva
prevederlo e poi l'ansia dai
pianificazione adesso cosa faccio
la necessità di riprendere subito il
controllo ora questo a pianificazione
imprevisti ripianificazione è un lavoro
psicologico immenso che ci occupa tutti
i giorni a me a me genera stress
a me personalmente mi si forma un
piccolo mattone qua sul petto che mi
impedisce di finire bene il respiro mi
sento un po chiuso in gabbia
e allora mi vengono di nuovo netto di
nuovo in discussione
possibile che non riesco a godermi
quella quotidianità che ho faticosamente
costruito in tanti anni
possibile che non riesco a vivere la mia
giornata con con maggiore leggerezza e
quindi iniziò a cercarmi delle evasioni
o di spazio solo per me quelle due ore
che ti prendi solo per ottenere a
giornata inizia a sognare ad occhi
aperti
le leggende metropolitane l'amico che ha
preso la famiglia è aperto il cie
indietro sulla spiaggia del paese
tropicale dove costa tutto pochissimo
c'è sempre il sole i bimbi giocano
scalzi nella sabbia
andiamo ma se pianificare mi genera
questo stress è lo stress in generale e
felicità voglia di evadere è sbagliato
pianificare e sbagliato pensare alle
conseguenze delle nostre azioni
è sbagliato pensare a chi vogliamo
essere nei diversi ruoli della nostra
vita
uomini donne genitori figli amici
colleghi e sbagliato impegnarsi per
realizzare i nostri sogni
evidentemente non è così è una
semplificazione che non vale non vale
perché il mondo di oggi e disordinato e
frammentato
è guidato da una tecnologia che a volte
sembra superare i nostri limiti di
pensiero e di azione
una tecnologia affascinante a volte
inquietante la usiamo per relazionarci
la usiamo per osservare per osservarci
la usiamo per scegliere continuamente e
scegliamo cosa ascoltare cosa leggere
cosa guardare come viaggiare
scegliamo continuamente e nello
scegliere abbiamo la sensazione di avere
il controllo
poi ci guardiamo intorno e vediamo sì un
mondo controllato ma condito da
insicurezza nevrosi disarmonia perché
viviamo in un mondo complesso perché è
difficile orientarsi in un mondo
complesso e complesso non vuol dire
complicato intendo complesso nel suo
significato originario compreso
significa intrecciato insieme è un
concetto di molteplicità è unita al
tempo stesso è un mondo che sia globale
sia locale
allo stesso tempo un mondo che va veloce
un mondo che è accelerato ogni cosa un
sistema sembra quasi che il mondo si sia
evoluto e sia entrato nell'era della
complessità e la nostra mente ancora no
che noi stessimo arrancando dietro
questo mondo e quindi fino adesso vi ho
buttato di qualche pensiero un po di
domande qualche banalità po di ansia
effettivamente se ci mettiamo a guardare
questo mondo ea pensare
c'è il rischio di rimanere paralizzati
io li capisco bene i giovani di oggi che
quelli quelli che non hanno voglia di
alzarsi dal letto quelli che non hanno
voglia di uscire di casa solo che io ho
due figlie piccole
cosa le racconto
avevo bisogno di un'ispirazione di
un'idea l'ho cercata
e forse lo trovate nel mondo dello sport
lo vivo tutti i giorni e racconta delle
storie straordinarie e credo che lo
sport sia in grado di trasmettere dei
valori e delle emozioni che sono uniche
vi siete mai chiesti perché le grandi
storie di sport ci coinvolgono così
tanto è che ci appassionano così tanto
due cose sono autentiche e sono
imprevedibili
provate a guardare un atleta nel momento
della sua gara nel momento della sua
partita nel suo momento
osservate per un attimo suo volto
guardate la tensione l'agone che ha in
quel momento e autentico e reale
lo sa che non ha un secondo ciak che non
ha un replay e sa anche che il risultato
imprevedibile perché ci sono statistiche
ci sono analisi ci sono sondaggi ci sono
calcoli complessi ma la fine il
risultato è sempre incerto e non è forse
questo quello di cui stiamo parlando non
è così la nostra vita quando affrontiamo
la complessità del mondo e vita vera ed
è imprevedibile
allora mi sono detto
guardiamo come fanno loro come fanno i
protagonisti di queste storie
straordinarie che guardo con tanta
ammirazione ad affrontare l'inevitabile
imprevedibilità delle loro sfide la
pressione dei media le aspettative dei
fan l'attimo che li paralizza prima di
entrare in campo c'era vanno anche loro
cosa fanno improvvisano semplificano
lasciano che sia il caso a decidere alla
vittoria o meno oppure hanno tutto sotto
controllo
stanno esattamente quale sarà il
risultato
beh nessuna delle due
o meglio entrambe si preparano al meglio
si allenano agendo su tutte le leve su
cui hanno il controllo l'alimentazione
la preparazione fisica e le cose le
analisi tecniche
la tecnologia e poi danno il massimo
senza risparmiarsi senza lasciare niente
a volte vincono
a volte perdono per bravura degli
avversari per un imprevisto per un
errore ma possono essere frustati
possono essere stressati se sanno che si
sono preparati al meglio e poi hanno
dato il massimo nel momento della
performance
ecco secondo me lo sport ci dà gli
strumenti per affrontare questa
complessità o quantomeno ci da
un'ispirazione allenarsi tutti i giorni
dando il meglio di noi e cercando di
imparare ogni giorno qualcosa di nuovo
con curiosità senza pigrizia e poi però
essere in grado di affrontare ogni
singolo evento della nostra vita
ogni momento con consapevole leggerezza
disciplinati ma non severi con noi
stessi responsabili ma non incolpa
coraggiosi nell'affrontare una nuova
sfida nell'uscire dalla nostra zona di
comfort senza essere bloccati dalla
paura di fallire perché il fallimento
non esiste il fallimento è un tentativo
che non andato a buon fine
esistono le sconfitte esistono le
delusioni esistono le ferite anche
profonde quelle che ti lasciano il segno
ma bisogna essere consapevoli che queste
ci servono soltanto a migliorare ed
accrescere essere più forti nel momento
in cui affronteremo la prossima sfida
ecco questo questa idea questo approccio
mi è piaciuta fin da subito mia mi ha
tolto un pezzettino di quel peso che
avevo qui e sto cercando di applicarla
nella nella quotidianità nel lavoro oggi
su questo palco con un successo più o
meno sono sta iniziando
e poi ho provato a portarla in un
progetto che andasse al di là di me
stesso che lasciasse il segno e insieme
ad alcuni soci e amici
abbiamo iniziato un avventura che
abbiamo chiamato actor che significa
agisci lei in esperanto e con atto
abbiamo due obiettivi quello di offrire
ai giovani dei paesi emergenti una
formazione professionale di qualità e
accessibile
e poi di offrire lo dei posti di lavoro
nelle opportunità di lavoro concrete nel
mondo dello sport siamo convinti che
l'educazione sia una delle sfide più
importanti per un futuro sostenibile del
nostro pianeta e crediamo nei valori
dello spot e vogliamo fare la nostra
piccola parte altro è stata lanciata lo
scorso anno a ottobre a capo verde e
quest'anno arriverà in portogallo e in
brasile coinvolgendo migliaia di giovani
offrendo centinaia di possibilità di
lavoro ce la faremo mi piacerebbe
potervi dire che sono sicuro ma il
futuro è imprevedibile
intanto ce la mettiamo tutta e ce la
giochiamo
grazie
[Applauso]